ايام مرت اذن على وقوع الزلزال جروح الالم
لم تندم بعد لكن الامر الواقع بات يقتضي
الان تجاوز الصدمه والتحضير لمرحله ما بعد
الكارثه في تركيا بدا الحديث عن خطط اعاده
الاعمار ومواعيد البدء فيها وذلك في
الولايات العشر المتضرره فعمليات رفع
الانقاض وازاله اثار الزلزال بدات في بعض
البلدات بينما تتواصلوا عمليات الانقاذ في
اخرى كما ردد ذلك مرارا رئيس تركيا
بردوغان فان اعمال اعاده الاعمار في
المناطق المنكوبه ستنطلق خلال ايام
التاكيد جاء على لسان وزير البيئه
والتخطيط العمراني التركي مراد كروم الذي
اعلن ان اعمال اعاده الاعمار في المناطق
المنكوبه جراء زلزلين ستبدا نهايه الشهر
الحالي ولحد الان فان حصيله الدمار تبدو
كبيره فنقلا عن الوزير التركي دائما فانه
تم تحديد
41791 مبنا متضرر من الزلزلين في الولايات
العشر علما ان عمليه تقييم الاضرار لم
تنتهي بعد بشكل كلي